let's take a look now at those latest
numbers brian nevada is reporting a new
record high positivity rate at slightly
over
22 percent that's over the last two
weeks
our state has also recorded a record
number of hospitalizations
at more than eighteen hundred and we
have more than a hundred and seventy six
thousand cases
and more than twenty three hundred
people have died meantime a snapshot
here what's going on in clark county it
does claim a majority of those cases
that more than a hundred and thirty
three thousand
more than two thousand new cases were
added as well as seventeen deaths
the recovery rate sitting at slightly
above eighty four
percent now our twenty two percent
positivity rate is really
higher than we were just less than two
weeks ago when the governor's
statewide pause went into effect so
where does that leave us
the i-team's david charns is here with
what we know about the next steps
david well denise it's the question we
all want answered right now what's
next when the governor's three-week
pause ends in just a week now this graph
behind me shows the positivity rate
this is where we were when the pandemic
started you see it's the highest there
all the way on the right side than it
has ever been before and much higher
than the lockdown this spring and yeah
the start of this pause
now two and a half weeks in now we have
asked the governor's office what could
be coming in terms of restrictions we
haven't heard back
we do know they are changing what
questions contract tracers are asking
people who test positive
that's simply because the number of
people they need to talk to
is so high right now with more than
those three thousand cases today alone
but
just look at this when the three week
pause began just before thanksgiving
we had a positivity rate of 17.1 we're
now at 22.3 as denise just mentioned
and the number of people hospitalized
here in nevada with kovid
more than doubling over the last month
we were at 1400 at the start of the
pause two weeks ago we're now at more
than
eighteen hundred of course the governor
is aware
of the timeline related to the
three-week pause
and an announcement related to the next
steps is likely to be made in the near
future
and and that with the understanding that
the end of the three-week
laws is less than a week away so as we
now await what's next state leaders did
tell us today iphone users can turn on a
new feature
alerting you if you are exposed to the
virus starting tomorrow you can turn on
what's called exposure
notification express it's right in your
iphone settings without having to
download the nevada
kovid trace app and new numbers just
released tonight show the united states
set records today for new coveted cases
hospitalizations
and deaths making it the worst day so
far state leaders did not say if any new
restrictions would be
in place would be put in place next week
or if they would be lifted
this three-week pause ending tuesday i'm
david charns 8 news now